من ملعب ريال مدريد سبق الزمن للحاق وفاه
الحارس الاسطوري للمنتخب المكسيكي هذه
الاخبار وغيرها نقدمها لكم من العربيه
رياضه اهلا بكم
فشل مهاجم مانشستر سيتي
امام ريال مدريد لكن والده الحاضر في
المدرجات خطف الاضواء منه بعد احتفاليه
بهدف التعادل للفريق الانجليزي هالاند
الاب احتفل بقوه واستفز مش ريال مدريد قبل
ان يتدخل الامن ويخرجه من منصه الشخصيه
المهمه تحت وابل من الشتائم قبلها
بابتسامه بارده
[موسيقى]
وعلى ارض الملعب خاض هالاند واحده من اسوا
مبارياته في الدوري الابطال صاحبه ليكيب
لم ترحم النجم النرويجي هنا تقييم ثلاثه
من عشره خلال المباراه وهو اسوء تقييم له
على الاطلاق وهذا بعد نحو شهرين فقط من
تقييم عشره من عشره امام لايف في احدى
الحالات النادره التي يتلقى فيها اللاعب
هذا التقييم من الجريده الفرنسيه
لا يزال مشجعهم الى ياملون في لحاق نجم
فريقهم رافايلياهو بمباراه الديربي امام
انتر النجم البرتغالي كان قد تعرض لاصابه
عضليه في مسابقه الدوري الايطالي ولم يحسم
الجهاز الفني بعد امر مشاركته وبحسب شبكه
سكاي سبورت ايطاليا فان قرار مشاركته
سيحسم قبل انطلاق المباراه المرتقبه والتي
تعتبر الاهم حتى الان في مشوار الرسوناري
هذا الموسم
في خبرين الاخير توفي اليوم اسطوره كره
القدم المكسيكيه انطونيو كارباخال عن عمر
النازل 93 وكان انطونيو قد شارك مع
المكسيك في 5 نسخه لكاس العالم بين عامي
و196 رقم قياسي بقي صامدا حتى نسخه 98 حين
عدله اسطوره المانيا لوثر ماتيوس